hier amtet christian herren als direktor
der bromer art collection
an der eröffnung des privatmuseums im
bernischen roggwil treffen potente
sammler aufstrebende künstler und die
diplomatie parliert mit der guten
gesellschaft
der junge kurator kann es mit allen auch
mit der schauspielernde ursula andress
die private kunstsammlung eines reichen
immobilienunternehmers soll dank
christian herren national und
international bekannt werden der star
der kunstwelt beherrscht der junge
kurator perfekt und er weiß genau wie
für den eröffnungsabend hat herren mit
der ganz grossen kelle angerichtet
der junge museumsdirektorin party stress
auf das gehört zum kuratoren alltag
einige tage später in st der 21-jährige
ausstellungsmacher trifft sich mit dem
bekannten spreng künstler roman signer
der altmeister und der junge kurator
bereiten eine ausstellung in san remo in
italien vor
der kurator ist auch transport gehilfe
er hat die zollpapiere für die
kunstwerke vorbereitet und christian
herren chauffiert die helvetische kunst
eigenhändig nach italien er kümmert sich
um die kleinen details denkt aber in
großen dimensionen
nachdenken über den eigenen berufsstand
inspirieren die geschenke zu machen und
unterschiedlichen kunststoffen die
zeigen wo es geht gut war fußballspielen
fußball karriere machen ein bisschen
intras talente zu kunst die junioren
risikobereitschaft
viele unabhängigen sachen lebte
als kurator muss er die welt an dass sie
manchmal dem alltag die kunst abringen
und christian hermes welten verbinden
san remo in der provinz imperia mit
druck will im kanton bern hier in der
villa des dynamit erfinders alfred nobel
kuratiert herren eine ausstellung die
sich dem berg und dem dynamit widmet
traditionelle helvetische alpen malerei
trifft auf die moderne videokunst von
signa
ich finde es interessant ist hier der
villa gnocchi oder zeigt aber und stand
ist sie vollständig vom dynamites unsere
zeit kunstwerk zum teil neue mir super
wird und oft ungleichen gleichzeitig
meter war vom romand raux man siegen
oder künste was auch immer noch mit
einer thematik auseinandersetzt
altes und neues verbinden zusammenhänge
sehen
auch dort wo sie nicht direkt erkennbar
sind das kam der nachwuchs kurator
und er hat die nötige kernkompetenz
flexibilität auch wenn der terminplan
drängt auf im letzten moment aber des
jahres arbeitet oder im auto
kurator sein heißt kumpel seien heran
versteht sich als partner der künstler
und des publikums
die vermittlerrolle lässt keine pause zu
es drehe immer weiter in seinem kopf
sagt er
das ziel ist eigentlich egal ob sein
fehlen coly rolf knie zum beispiel der
kurator aus der kurator zwei
interessante neue kunst zeigt aber
gleichzeitig von einem breiten publikum
offen standen wird also möglichst früh
zwei interessante welt von kunst
man ahnt es braucht vor allem
überdurchschnittlichen ehrgeiz damit man
mit 21 jahren als kurator erfolgreich
sein kann